cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film maman a tort réalisé par marc
fitoussi avec emilie dequenne et jeunes
geste un stage en entreprise
tu pourras même étudiant qui connais ton
vraiment ses parents à nous 14 ans
découvre brutalement un autre visage de
sa mère à la faveur de l'incontournable
stage d'observation de troisième qu'elle
effectue dans la compagnie d'assurance
ou celle ci travaille et infini dans le
monde du travail
une semaine d'immersion dans le monde
adulte de l'entreprise avec ses petits
arrangements et ses grandes lâchetés qui
bientôt celle son jeune destin entre
parcours initiatique fêlures et première
responsabilité à assumer une forme
d'adieu à l'enfant que c'est mort
va être expulsé pourquoi t'as pas pris
le tapis
comment tu veux vérifier sans dossiste
campagne papier sans clichés avec
beaucoup de justesse ce film n'est pas
la réalité de l'entreprise
quand ces compromissions à travers le
regard d'une collégienne skirail et
entreprend de faire si le monde adulte
est encore plus riche qu'il ait rien
faire intelligent subtil et ponctuée de
vraies situations comiques avec des
seconds rôles hilarants
le film excellent dans la description
des personnages il révèle des talents
lumineux de la jeune john jesta quant à
emilie dequenne elle incarne à merveille
ce rôle de mère décevante voire lâchant
les kits je pensais mettre l'enfant du
placard à man à tort est une comédie
dramatique à ne pas manquer et elle est
à découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
failli pleurer